It's been, gosh, almost two whole decades
since Firefly went off the air, and the show's
fans have been peppered with false hope at
least once a year ever since.
Rumors of reunion specials, Serenity sequels,
and Netflix reboots have made the rounds like
so many signals you can't stop.
Nathan Fillion cosplayed as Captain Reynolds
on Castle, which devotees saw as a sure sign
that the crew would keep flying soon enough.
An MMO was announced in 2013, complete with
voice work from the original cast, but it
disappeared without so much as a "sorry we
got you all worked up" from the development
team.
It is, therefore, with some degree of caution
that the following update is relayed: Word
is making the rounds that Disney is working
on a Firefly reboot, intended for release
on its Disney+ streaming service.
That update comes courtesy of Giant Freakin
Robot, and while a reminder to do like The
Who taught you and not get fooled again might
come as a given, the rumor appears to have
legs.
It's all thanks to the continuing downturn
in the financial viability of theatrical releases,
and a company-wide shift towards more televised
content.
Firefly, which joined the Disney vault as
part of the company's 2019 acquisition of
all Fox entertainment properties, is seen
as a viable universe to explore given the
studio's direct-to-consumer emphasis.
But it's not the return of a beloved cult
franchise that's turning the most heads — it's
the rumored Disneyfication of the series that
appears to be coming with it.
Per Giant Freakin Robot's source, Disney's
return to the Firefly universe is set to make
some staggering changes, not the least of
which is that the series would reportedly
be a hard reboot, recasting and restarting
every character from the beginning.
That's bound to draw the ire of diehard fans,
as will the studio's proposed plan to make
the new series "PG rated" in the hopes of
creating a more family-friendly end product.
Firefly, in its short-lived run on Fox back
in 2002, was a decidedly bleak story defined
by its morally gray plots and characters.
In the Firefly Universe, prostitution is a
noble line of work, dogs are eaten, and high-ranking
boss battle minions get kicked into turbines
to better make a point.
The good guys do bad things, and the bad guys
do worse things, with frequent allusions to
forced brain surgery, wholesale civilian slaughter,
and sexual violence factoring into the show's
plot.
It seems like a peculiar universe to try and
sand the edges off of, but that's reportedly
what Disney intends to do.
Details on the show's production are slim
at the moment, with reports that the Firefly
reboot is in such early days that it wasn't
yet ready for Disney's recent Investors Day
presentation.
Perhaps the biggest question on fans' minds
will be whether or not original showrunner
and series creator Joss Whedon will be involved,
given the recent string of bizarre allegations
surrounding the acclaimed filmmaker.
There's no word yet, but it seems unlikely
that the show will break atmo without Whedon
at least offering his two cents.
While Browncoats wait for more news about
the rumored reboot, there's still plenty of
Firefly lore to explore.
Since the show went off the air, Dark Horse
and Boom!
Studios have produced dozens of comic book
continuations of the story, written by geek
royalty like Patton Oswalt and even Joss Whedon
himself.
The franchise has spawned novelization, reference
books, RPGs, board games, and a cook book
since its untimely removal from the airwaves.
Given that the original series only lasted
half a season, the fact that it spawned so
much content might seem impossible — but
then again, that's what makes it mighty.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.